حسنًا ، وصفتها المتحدثة باسم وزارة الخارجية
بأنها صورة قبيحة للغاية ،
حيث تقول إن الغرب يضع
كل الاهتمام والتركيز على ما
يحدث في أوكرانيا للضغط على
روسيا وكل ما قالته
ينتقص أثناء دورة الألعاب الأولمبية
في بكين.  المزيد من الانتقادات القادمة
من أه المسؤولين هنا في روسيا
بينما يستعد الرئيس ماكرون
للقاء يوم الاثنين مع الرئيس
بوتين
حيث سيتحدث الاثنان
عن طرق خفض التصعيد
وتقليل التوترات الحالية
يتحدث الرئيس الفرنسي أه يوم السبت  مع
كل من بوريس جونسون رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني والأمين العام
لحلف الناتو جين ستالتنبرغ ومن المثير للاهتمام أن كلا الزعيمين أوصيا ونصح الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون بالحفاظ على
وحدة الناتو
للحفاظ على قوة الرسالة تلك عندما
يتحدث مع الرئيس بوتين أن الناتو
هو  كلها متوافقة وهذه هي
الرسالة نفسها التي تلقاها الرئيس ماكرون
في مكالمته الهاتفية قبل يومين
مع الرئيس بايدن وفي اليوم السابق
لذلك مع رئيس وزراء كندا
جاستن
ترودو ولماذا يقولون هذا جزئيًا
لأن جزءًا من
أجندة الرئيس ماكرون ليس فقط
لإحداث  بعض محادثات السلام بين
السلطات الأوكرانية
والانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا في شرق
أوكرانيا وأيضًا لحمل الرئيس بوتين
على تهدئة التوترات وتقليل
وجود القوات أه حول أوكرانيا
لكنه يريد نوعًا من رسم
سياسة خارجية أقوى  وصوت الدفاع
عن الاتحاد الأوروبي داخل الناتو
ومن الواضح أن هناك مخاوف لدى البعض من أن
ذلك سوف يكسر صورة وحدة
الناتو التي تُعرض على الرئيس
بوتين لكن مكتب هذا أه
الرئيس ماكرون يقول إنه لا
يتوقع اختراقات ضخمة يوم الإثنين
لكن أه الكرملين وصف
الرئيس  ماكرون كمحاور جيد
نيك روبرتسون سي إن إن موسكو